The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So I want
to start with a small puzzle,
if I can get this thing to work.
This is satellite capture
of carbon monoxide plumes
globally.
I'll let this run for
a while, and then I'll
show you another one that's
got more information but harder
to read.
So the question is why?
Why are they where
they are, which
requires you to first figure
out where carbon monoxide comes
from--
which I figure most
of you probably know.
Quick response-- how do
you get carbon monoxide
in the atmosphere in quantity.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Burning hydrocarbons.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Burning
hydrocarbons completely,
incompletely?
AUDIENCE: Incompletely.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Incompletely.
So it's incomplete
combustion of hydrocarbons.
So you see the red spots is
where there's a lot of it.
A lot of energy is
burning hydrocarbons,
so it's not too surprising
we have this here.
Let me start the other
one, which gives you
a little bit of the same.
You see a lot over Asia,
India, South Asia, Africa,
some over Latin America.
Why?
How come we're seeing incomplete
combustion of hydrocarbons
in those areas?
A lot of it-- enough to make
plumes detectable from space.
How come?
Thoughts?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A lot of those
are developing areas,
and they don't have the tissue
processes to burn hydrocarbons.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's right.
Let me restart this thing.
So we're dealing with--
a lot of those are
developing areas.
What kind of
hydrocarbons do you think
they're burning in quantity?
And the plume that you
occasionally see over Brazil
is a fair amount of
deforestation in the Amazon,
just large-scale burning.
But what kind of
hydrocarbons do you
find being burned in
very poor countries?
AUDIENCE: Coal.
Coal.
Wood.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Coal's one answer.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Wood.
Wood.
I hear mumbling.
It's very hard to
grade participation
when you do chorus.
So just put up a hand.
Take a shot at it.
Wood's what I was after.
They do burn coal,
and we're going
to see a fair amount of
that, but this is UN data
on the fraction of total energy
from quote, "primary biomass,"
which is largely wood--
wood and brush and
stuff like that.
And you will notice
how high it is
in a number of poor countries.
I was struck by the
Cambodia number,
just because I was
there recently.
But look at Ethiopia.
Almost all the energy available.
And these are estimates.
You can't measure how much
they're doing and cooking
fires in remote villages, but
the dominant energy source
in those two very poor
countries is gathering wood
and burning it to cook.
Most of the time, most of
the energy data you will see
does not have that, in part
because the best you can do
is estimate it.
But historically, this is very
important as an energy source,
and it's still important in a
lot of developing countries.
We will come back to this.
That's one source of
energy that humans
use to supplement their
own before we began
using fossil fuels in quantity.
What else did we use?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Water.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Water, like water power,
water wheels of various kinds.
Anything else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Wind.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Wind--
sailing ships, windmills.
Anything else?
David.
AUDIENCE: Horses.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Animals, yeah.
And the availability of all
of those things varies a lot.
I'm sorry about the fly in.
I'm a little careless in
setting up the animation.
The availability of all
of those energy sources
varies enormously globally.
If you're in a desert, you're
not gathering a lot of wood
to burn.
If you're in Africa, you're
short of domesticated animals,
and so on.
If you look across
pre-industrial economies,
and you ask what do their
energy systems look like,
they're going to
differ, depending
on available resources.
They're going to differ
depending on climate.
Do you really need to heat?
Is it really important?
They're going to differ
level of technology, which
varied a lot in
pre-industrial times,
particularly because
communication
was slow and erratic, and
the level of organization.
When the Roman Empire fell,
energy systems changed,
organization changed.
So I'm sure there are
other differences.
So today, what we're
going to look at--
and just briefly, this is a
little bit like Wednesday's.
This will, I think,
set a record,
which I hope not to break,
for the number of slides.
But this is background
and overview
of what the world's
energy systems look like.
One of the important
things to think about
is when you go beyond--
this is the fancy slide
that I showed you last time
about national energy
systems in context.
If you look at the
global energy system,
it's more than a set
of national ones.
There's a global
background-- if you will,
a social background of cultural
communications, rivalry,
emulation, and so forth.
Greenhouse gases
are a global issue.
There is a set of international
institutions and regimes--
the World Trade Organization,
climate agreements,
NAFTA, et cetera, et cetera,
that affect the global system.
There are international
energy markets,
international
financial markets, and
transnational
multinational firms
that link the global markets.
So we don't have a
single world energy
market, and that'll become clear
as we go through the course.
But we do have a lot of linkages
between national markets.
So let's look first
at what's the world
look like in aggregate?
What does the US look
like in the world?
Then we'll look at
some differences.
So that's what the world burns.
You will notice there really
isn't any biomass up there.
This is from BP, formerly
known as British Petroleum.
This is how the
standard statistics go.
You've got oil, natural
gas, nuclear, hydro power,
the tiny little non-hydro
renewables, and then coal
on top.
For the US, coal
was very important.
For the world, oil is the most
important in terms of energy
content.
Oil's share has been declining
for some time, however.
You'll notice the total
world consumption is growing.
Oil looks pretty flat.
Oil share's declining.
Oil share is declining at the
expense of natural gas not too
surprising in the US context.
But the importance
of coal is growing,
which is a little odd if you
think about it, because coal
was the first of the
fossil fuels that
were used to any extent and it's
now on a global basis growing.
And we'll come back to that.
So in terms of the US--
these are a year or two old,
but they're about right,
we're about 4 and 1/2% of
the world's population.
We produce about 15%
of primary energy.
We consume over 20%.
5% of the world's
population-- less than 5%
consuming more than 20%
of the world's energy.
A theme I will sound
today is the whole world
can't live like we do.
The arithmetic doesn't work.
This is the point that
Tom Friedman makes
in the article on the list.
He makes it in more
colorful fashion,
but the numbers
are pretty clear.
And we'll come back to that.
This is almost
illegible, but this
is more than five metric
tons of oil equivalent
per capita, and down
to less than 1 and 1/2.
You see enormous
variation in the amount
of energy consumed per
capita, with the US, Canada,
Saudi Arabia, and a few European
countries clearly in the lead.
And countries where
there was all that carbon
monoxide-- many of them,
very low down in terms
of using commercial energy.
So there's a lot of gathered
wood being done in those areas.
Not a lot of commercial energy.
Russia's high, Norway's high.
I think that's Norwegian.
In any case, lots of
energy, lots of variation.
If you look at energy
use per capita over time,
you will see as we saw last time
for the US, it's pretty flat.
Slightly different data source,
slightly different measures,
but flat for the
US for a long time.
Considerably higher than
other rich countries.
And here's the world
average per capita.
Here's the US.
Here's China rapidly growing
toward the world average
per capita, the growth of
China being a very big story
that I'll spend a little
more time on today
and then come back to.
So if any of this stuff
raises questions, by the way,
raise your hand.
This is a session with a
fair amount of me talking.
But if I have to just talk
the whole way through,
it'll be boring for
both of us-- all of us.
David
AUDIENCE: Why are we double what
France and Germany [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's a
really good question, isn't it?
We're going to want
to explore that.
Let me not say an
answer right now,
but have you been to Europe?
AUDIENCE: No.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
You will notice that
the houses are smaller.
Many of the cars are smaller.
The cities are denser.
The railroads, the passenger
railroads, are better.
The activity mix is different.
The countries are denser.
There are a whole
set of reasons.
It's not that we're bad
people, although maybe we're
bad people.
But there are
differences in history,
differences in circumstances.
I'll show you how
several of these--
I don't think I
have the UK, what
several of the energy structures
in these countries look like.
We worry about imported oil.
That's all they
have, so you would
think they might act a little
differently toward using
automobiles.
So there are a bunch of reasons.
We'll spend some time on it.
It's important to understand
why countries differ if you want
to change things going forward.
It's important to
see what history
has done to get a sense
of what you can do.
But just think about how
we use energy, how energy
could be used differently.
I mean, people in
those countries
live perfectly pleasant
lives by our standards.
They're just different.
There was another hand.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I can't remember
what it was in the reading.
I think it was [INAUDIBLE].
But I remembered [INAUDIBLE]
Japan [INAUDIBLE] was less than
China's.
Or maybe it was in the
units of America [INAUDIBLE]
that Japan had, like, one and
China was [INAUDIBLE] two.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Per
dollar of GDP, Japan is lower.
This is per person.
And China, despite its rapid
increase in wealth and income,
is still a poor
country on average,
and certainly in '07 was.
I mean, that graph
goes up from '07.
Anything else?
OK, this is gives
you a little sense.
Tells you that the world
differs in how it uses energy.
This is from BP, and
this is by region.
So you will notice
that in Asia-Pacific,
which will be heavily China,
Australia, New Zealand, coal
is the dominant fuel.
In the Middle East, not
too surprisingly, it's
oil and natural
gas, and there are
various mixtures in-between.
Here's North America.
We use a lot of oil.
We use a lot of natural gas.
We use a fair amount of coal.
So there are regional
differences in part
because, with the
exception of oil--
well, not even with
the exception of oil,
transporting this stuff
globally is not that easy.
It's easier than it used to
be, but transporting coal,
to transport natural
gas, you either
build a pipeline or
you liquefy it, put it
in a very expensive
ship and move it.
So the regional differences in
patterns of energy use-- again,
we'll come back to
this reflect in part
differences in endowments,
and in part transport costs.
OK, David asked about why France
and the US differ in energy,
or European countries differ
from the US in energy use.
Let me ask a broader question.
What factors determine
differences in structure,
not just in level?
But if you try to compare
two countries, what might
you look at to
compare differences
in where they get energy
and how they use it?
Anybody, take a shot.
Erica, you're writing
very, very diligently,
and I didn't say that much.
What would you look at?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
To explain differences
between countries in how they
get and how they use energy.
AUDIENCE: Well, one of
[INAUDIBLE] available resources
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Available resources, yeah,
that's a gimme.
I hit the thing too quickly.
Can you give me another one?
AUDIENCE: The standard
government, or [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So government policies,
which would come out of
the political system.
That's another one.
Anything else?
Mathoura?
AUDIENCE: Very good.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I
hesitated, you'll notice.
AUDIENCE: One thing would be
also, like, transportation.
Like for example, if
the country's landlocked
or if it has access
to waterways,
it has a good system that
allows the transport of oil
in and out of the country
and to various regions.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's a good point.
It's not one that's on my list.
It's the geography
of the country.
Can you get various energy
sources like oil by tanker,
or do you have to pipe it
in or take it in by rail?
Another influence
is geography, which
is in available resources.
Do you have water,
do you have wind?
Yeah, Alex.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say development history.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Development history?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so like what's
happened in the past-- like,
how developed
there's this country?
Was there previous
economic history?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So the
previous economic history
would be both, say, level of
income, level of development,
and you're suggesting how
they got there would matter.
Say a little more.
AUDIENCE: Or like how
fast they got there.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: How
fast they got there, OK.
Did they develop in the 19th
century and put a lot of money
into 19th century assets
that are still going,
or did they develop
recently and were
able to use new technology?
That's a very nice point.
The Chinese are building
lots of power plants.
Their power plants
are, on average,
more efficient than ours because
they're much younger than ours
on average.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like,
population density.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Population density.
James, OK.
AUDIENCE: It would
be easier per person
to heat, like, an apartment
building in Japan--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So density?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: --as opposed
to a bunch of big houses,
but across Texas, per person.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: We
always come back to Texas,
don't we really?
[CHUCKLES] Some of that's
just people per square mile
and some of it
reflects policy, how
you react to sprawl when
you're doing land use
policy and other things.
So both things matter.
Exactly right.
Yeah, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: Well the sort
of products that you make
and the products
that you consume.
So like, an agrarian society
might use so much oil,
but somebody who's going
to be manufacturing
of a certain product would
definitely use a lot more.
Also, if you're making a
product for your own country,
then you're going to make a
product for your own country.
So the consumption is
going to be higher,
so you're going to make more.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So the activity mix.
So you get less
energy if the country
is a financial
center, like England,
than if it's a manufacturing
center, like China.
When we looked at the variation
in energy use across US states,
Wyoming was very high.
And I neglected to
mention last time
that one of the big things
that goes on in Wyoming
is strip mining of coal
in huge quantities,
using very, very
large machinery,
and not a lot of
people doing this.
So that's rather different
from what goes on in Manhattan.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I would say political
and geographical relations
with foreign exporters.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
how you can get your access
to the world markets, the terms
on which you can access them.
Who is nearby, not
just what do you have.
So China can get coal from
Australia, for instance,
in ways that would be
more complicated if they
were farther away and
Australia didn't speak to them.
And actually, I was talking
to somebody about getting--
the country of Lebanon
evidently built its power plants
assuming it would get
natural gas to run them.
It has to run them on oil
because it can no longer get
natural gas from its neighbors.
And as a result,
efficiency is cut in half.
So these things do matter.
Orson, you were--
AUDIENCE: I think
that, [INAUDIBLE]
if you're going to try and
develop a type of engine that's
going to be sustainable
for your own country,
you want to try to do
something that the technology
in your country is
there, and there's
the people who are
educated to develop
those types of technologies.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So what
you're saying is you could--
we talked about policy
just in general terms.
But you're saying
very specifically,
energy policy could focus
on a particular technology,
develop local expertise
in that technology--
develop a cluster of people
who could then advance it,
and make it more efficient
and more usable and more
friendly for you, and
more economical for you.
I think that's a good list.
And for an economist,
it's a great list.
I would, however, add one
other thing, which is culture--
culture and habits.
I mean, the Germans
recycle relentlessly.
We don't.
I mean, we do, but it's nothing
like recycling in Germany.
It's nothing like concern
for materials and packaging
in Germany.
It's nothing like concern
for efficiency in Japan
or in Germany.
The culture does matter
and does affect--
let's see, I think I've
got everything we said.
Everything that people
decide to do-- the habits.
Americans are persuaded,
we should drive.
Automobiles are important.
Well, that's not God-given.
That's just part of the culture.
So those things do matter.
And one of the
things I mentioned
when I talked about
pre-industrial is
climate in the sense of
how hot and how cold.
This is an old graph on heating
and cooling requirements.
I don't want to go into how
do you measure a degree day,
in part because
I don't remember.
But it's a measure of how
much you need to spend cooling
and how much you need
to spend heating.
Obviously, Russia
spends a lot-- has
to spend a fair
amount of energy.
Heating, Bangladesh,
not so much.
And of course, before the advent
of economical air conditioning,
these countries did very
little to deal with the weather
because they couldn't.
Now that you can,
India in particular,
you do see more
air conditioning,
and it is an important
use of energy.
Another way, just to do some
more of these comparisons,
this is requirements.
This is a little
bit of the influence
of a couple of things--
first, activity mix,
and second, efficiency.
This is energy intensity.
Basically, tons of oil
equivalent per dollar of GDP.
It's an old graph.
It hasn't changed that much.
You'll notice that Kenya
uses a lot of energy
per dollar of GDP.
Is that because Kenya is
doing massive high-energy
manufacturing, or is that
because Kenyan technology tends
to be old and inefficient?
So per dollar of GDP, they end
up wasting a lot of energy.
Japan, you will notice, uses
less per dollar of GDP--
and this may be what
you remember than China.
Less than the US, Japan
has very expensive energy
for a variety of reasons--
very high prices,
very dense cities, very small
residences by our standards,
and per dollar of
GDP, even though it
does a fair amount of
manufacturing a lot less.
The Russian story
is a combination.
Again, this is 2003.
It's a combination
of historically lots
of heavy industry and
cheap energy that led
to inefficient capital stock.
In Soviet times, they built
some of the most amazingly
inefficient stuff
you could imagine
because energy was subsidized.
Anyplace else you worry
about energy costs,
they worried less.
So Germany does a
lot of manufacturing.
It's more efficient than we are.
Its energy is more expensive.
So I will pause there
to see if anything
strikes you or anything
you'd want to comment on.
I mean, you can run these data
we'll do a little bit of this
later.
This is a bizarre graph.
This shows changes over time.
You may wonder why
the Russian Federation
jumps up right after 1990.
That's, of course, because the
Russian Federation didn't exist
before 1990, and whoever did
this graph couldn't quite
do a not present.
But you'll see a
couple of things.
There's the US.
Again, this is energy
per dollar of GDP.
We showed last time a decline.
Look at the decline in China.
Look at the decline in energy
per dollar of GDP in China.
This is just getting
more efficient
because GDP is rising.
They're using new equipment.
This is just an enormous
increase in efficiency.
This is not doing
less manufacturing.
It's just becoming
more efficient.
There's a general-- and again,
Russia, enormously inefficient,
coming down over time as
they begin to modernize
their industrial plant.
The others, there's a
general downward trend
if you've got an eye for it
among most of these developed
countries, but it's slight.
In Russia and China,
they had a lot
of inefficient heavy industry.
The trend is very
pronounced, but China
is a very energy-intensive
operation.
One of the things, of course,
that drives energy structure
is prices faced by
people making decisions.
We didn't mention prices
on the earlier list
because prices don't
drop out of the sky.
They come from,
among other things,
most of the things on the list.
These are gasoline prices, 2006.
The units are
dollars per gallon.
I assume a US gallon.
But you'll notice the big
difference between Germany here
at $6, the US at $2.50 at
that point, China $2.11.
And if the graph
had more countries,
I'm sure we'd see around $1 in
Venezuela, maybe $1 and a half
in Egypt.
Huge range of
prices for gasoline,
which is traded
internationally, which gets
shipped around the
world on large tankers.
That's policy.
That's mostly policy.
The Europeans and the
Koreans don't have oil.
They tax it.
The Japanese tax it.
We tax it, but not so much.
Mexico has a fair amount of oil.
They tax it less, and
other countries actively
subsidize the
consumption of gasoline,
Venezuela being the most
glaring that I'm aware of.
You may ask politically--
and this is the kind
of question we're
going to come to, how come?
How come Germany makes a
political decision to tax
the heck out of
gasoline, and Venezuela,
even before the Chavez regime,
makes a political decision
to spend tax money to
subsidize gasoline?
I'm not going to
answer that question.
But it is the question.
It is a social science of energy
question-- kind of a basic one.
How does that decision get made?
Here's another one.
These are electricity
prices, and you'll
see there are two
bars for each country.
The darker one is
household prices.
And again, there's
an effective policy.
Prices differ between
countries that are nearby.
Let's see if I
can find a couple.
Here's the Czech Republic
and here's Germany.
That difference in
residential prices
presumably reflects
policy, among other things.
The lighter-colored bar
is what industry pays.
Now, industry will always
pay less than households,
typically because it'll take
power at higher voltages,
there are lower costs, lots of
reasons why the light bar is
always below the dark bar.
But look at how
big the differences
are in some countries
and how small in others.
That's just a-- compare
what happens in Norway,
where that's got to
be more than double,
with what we got
here, Italy, where
those prices are quite close.
That is, in many of
these countries--
most of these countries, the
outcome of a political process.
Electricity prices are
importantly political.
Many of these are government-run
electricity companies.
The ones that aren't in
the US are least regulated,
and the outcome of
the regulatory process
is, as we will
discuss, political.
So when we talk about prices,
where do prices come from?
I'll just list a few
here, rather than
spend a while on
this, because I want
to make sure I get through this
massive collection of slides.
Sometimes, prices
reflect cost differences.
We have a lot of coal.
Other people don't.
Electricity is
cheaper in the Midwest
because there's a lot of coal
and coal-fired power plants.
OK, that's local resources.
People use oil to
generate electricity.
The price of electricity varies
with the world price of oil.
Some countries, capital
and labor are cheap.
Some countries are expensive.
We talked about some countries
have efficient technology,
some countries don't.
And it's not just
level of development--
not just level of development.
It is, for instance,
house size--
how large your house is,
how well-insulated are they.
Different rich countries
have different answers
to that question.
Taxes and subsidies,
that's political.
And one thing we
haven't mentioned
is environmental policy.
US, Europe, pretty tight
environmental policies.
Lots to debate.
China, not so much.
Russia, not so much.
Those policies affect the costs
of producing and using energy.
You can think of other
things that affect prices,
but I think those
are the big ones.
You could do this whole
session on electricity.
There are lots of
people in this world who
are off-grid who don't have
any electricity at all.
So we don't have
electricity prices for them.
And this isn't price.
This is consumption per capita.
Notice the world
leader is Iceland.
Does anybody know why?
Anybody know how electricity
is produced in Iceland?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thermoelectric
generation.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It's geothermal.
They use geothermal heat.
It's really cheap--
really cheap,
and that's a local resource.
Norway-- anybody know what the
dominant method for producing
electricity in Norway is?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hydroelectricity.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Hydroelectricity.
Norway has a lot of hydropower.
And again, if you're
lucky in geography,
you can have cheap
electricity from hydropower.
Are you willing to
build a lot of dams?
Norwegians are also
environmentalists,
so they do worry about the dams.
And Qatar is third.
What do you think they
do, or what do they have?
It's a tiny little country
in the Persian Gulf.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oil.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: What?
AUDIENCE: Oil?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, oil is a good guess.
It's close.
It's natural gas.
They have literally
boatloads of natural gas.
They liquefy it and
export it in quantity,
and they use it locally
to generate electricity.
Back in the bad old
days, they would just
burn it to get rid of it.
Now they spend a lot of money
freezing it, liquefying it,
and selling it.
But look at the world number.
Compare how much electricity we
consume with the world average.
We're not among the leaders.
We're pretty high, but we're
not the top two or three.
But the world average,
my heavens, my heavens,
less than a quarter--
less than a quarter.
OK, what I want to do
for a little while--
you may remember this
picture from last time.
This is one of those
great visual displays
of quantitative information
from Lawrence Livermore.
Lawrence Livermore, if
you go on their website,
you can find these for 2007,
which is why I have 2007,
for something like
100 countries.
So if you're curious about what
energy looks like in country X,
you can find a bunch of them.
And I'm going to show
you some variation.
I do want to make a couple
of points about the US,
because it'll relate
to others we will see.
Notice most of our
natural gas is domestic.
Most of our coal is domestic.
In fact, our exports for coal in
that year exceeded our imports.
We import biomass.
I have no idea what that is, but
our worry about imports is oil.
You'll notice for electricity,
we do a lot of coal
and nuclear and gas,
a little bit of wind
and a little bit of solar.
Now, you may wonder what this
little yellow line, which is
solar going into residential.
What is that?
Solar energy used
in the household.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that where people
have their own solar panels
and use that to keep their
homes, pools, et cetera,
potentially
[INAUDIBLE] the grid?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, probably in 2007,
it's a little bit
too big for that.
But you're right about the
rooftop, at least in part--
solar hot water heaters.
And we actually lead the
world in use of solar energy
because we do a lot of swimming
pools heated with solar energy.
If you take that out,
we're not so good.
But a lot of this is solar
heating of swimming pools--
a critical thing.
OK, so let me do a few.
And again, raise
questions if weird things
strike you or don't strike you.
This is France.
What do you see in the
electricity side for France?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A lot of nuclear.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
A lot of nuclear--
a lot of nuclear.
France made a
strategic commitment
to nuclear power years ago.
Those plants are very expensive.
They're going to
last a long time.
There they are.
You don't turn them off.
You don't turn them
off right away.
Almost all the coal
they use is imported.
Almost all the natural
gas is imported.
Almost all the oil is imported.
Nuclear has energy
security benefits
for France, which is
an important reason
for that decision.
It also makes France a
leader in nuclear technology.
To come back to Everson's point
about building an industry
and building a critical
mass, it's had that effect.
France exports reactors,
exports designs--
a decision, but also a
decision based on the fact
that the natural endowment of
these fossil fuels is terrible.
You can drill a long time and
you're not going to find oil.
They apparently have some.
I have no idea where it
is, but not a lot of it.
OK, let's look at
another country.
This is Norway.
And as we saw up here, the big--
unfortunately,
different countries
have different sized
bars on everything.
But you'll see the big
thing in electricity
is hydro, as we
discussed earlier.
Norway is lucky.
They have a lot of natural
gas, most of which they export.
They have a lot of oil,
most of which they export.
That's a country with lots
of natural endowments.
They use some of
the natural gas.
They use some of the oil
to generate electricity.
And apparently, they
even burn some wood.
But mostly, they
rely on hydropower,
and they export the
natural gas and the oil.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So Norway has really
high electricity consumption.
And he explained that the
reason's mostly due to hydro?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Cheap hydro.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Right, but Brazil also
has a cost of 70% to 80% hydro.
But we looked at the
electricity consumption graph,
it was not even listed.
Is there a reason for that?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I don't
know electricity prices
in Brazil.
I did look at this
thing for Brazil.
Brazil is running
about 30% hydro
maybe-- something like that.
It's pretty high.
But they may also tax it.
In a country like Brazil,
where a lot of poor people
don't have electricity,
electricity becomes--
as it was in the United
States, say, through the '20s,
it becomes predominantly
consumed by wealthier people.
So it becomes something
you might want
to tax for political reasons.
I'm just guessing.
I don't know that, and
I don't know the cost
of Brazil's fossil fuel plants.
They don't have
coal, so I assume
the fossil is mostly oil.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
oil is not that cheap.
Oil is not that cheap to
generate electricity with.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For the
right-hand side,
for the uses of the energy, what
does the non-energy box mean?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Chemicals mostly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Use oil.
I mean, in the later US graph
that I showed last time,
it didn't appear.
Lawrence Livermore kept
it until quite recently.
And I read that-- since
the only thing that
ever goes in there is
oil and natural gas,
I view that as the
chemical industry.
They're not burning it.
They're using it
for petrochemicals.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why does
it [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Different
parts of the country.
Maybe it's that they've got--
I would guess this
is refined product.
So maybe there is a
refinery in Sweden, say,
that happens to be
close to a major source,
so it's just easier to
import some from Sweden.
Normally, this happens, and
you see it a lot of places--
well, you see it
here in electricity.
For instance, they
import electricity
and they export electricity.
That's geography.
You've got a line going here
where demand exceeds supply.
You got a line over here
where supply exceeds demand,
and we do too.
You import one energy
export at the other.
I would assume that
this is refined product
that they're getting.
There happens to be a
convenient refinery that's
willing to sell, and they're
exporting mostly crude.
But normally, that's
what this will be.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do most countries have
the same breakdown of energy
services in rejected energy?
Are there some type
of [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I
haven't looked at it.
I assume they're similar,
because it has to do with--
I mean, it's inefficiency.
So you're going to
lose a bunch up here,
depending on how efficient
your generation plant is.
And how you do the efficiency
for hydro and nuclear
is just a tricky
definitional issue.
Everybody's going
to have more reject.
I thought you'd have
more rejected than used.
I think that's what
we have, isn't it?
Let's take a look.
There's France with
more rejected than used.
There's the US is more
rejected than used.
And there are the Norwegians.
Aside from the
size of the blocs,
the numbers say more
used than rejected.
Got me.
You got me.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
it's due to the fact
that, like, hydroelectricity
is a lot more efficient, as
opposed to, like, nuclear
coal burns off a lot,
and a lot of heat is
lost or not transferred.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That may
just be how you define it.
How do you define the
efficiency of a hydro plant?
I don't know what they do
in terms of the efficiency.
I'd have to look.
In transportation, you've
got more waste than used.
In industrial, the reverse.
In household, in commercial,
yeah, if I read--
I can't tell how much
is going down here.
I can't sort it out by sector.
That's a departure.
Most countries have
more rejected than used.
It might be the hydro.
Yeah, Matthew.
AUDIENCE: What would
cause a country that
has such large domestic amounts
of natural gas and petroleum
to develop hydro like they do?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They
developed the hydro earlier.
So the hydro is earlier, and
then they found the natural gas
and petroleum offshore later.
And they worked very
hard at learning
how to manage hydro systems.
It's actually a little tricky
because it doesn't always rain
and the snow doesn't always
melt when you want it to.
And they also worked very
hard to develop hydro
without wrecking
the environment.
So once you've got
that capability
and you're good at it, and
you've got the geography
and you discover you've got
a lot of natural gas and oil
offshore, it may make
more sense to export
that than to burn it locally.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you please give
examples of energy services
which is [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, energy services?
Driving, running factories.
And this is mostly
heating, ventilating,
and air conditioning, but
electric ranges, refrigerators,
running your computer,
et cetera, et cetera,
all the things you use it for.
This is puzzling.
AUDIENCE: But doesn't it come
from the electricity and heat?
I would [INAUDIBLE] it on
the left side of that box.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, your computer
doesn't use 100% of the
energy and the electricity
for useful work.
There's waste heat.
Your refrigerator wastes--
there's waste heat that
comes off the refrigerator.
AUDIENCE: There's
more [INAUDIBLE]
services than
electricity and heat.
There's 640 versus--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
here you're running machinery.
I mean-- oh, I see
what you're saying.
I mean, here you're running
a car from gasoline.
Here, you are running
machinery of various kinds.
I don't know.
I'd have to list it.
And you're also burning
oil directly to heat.
You're burning oil directly
to heat in all these places.
We'll go through
some other examples,
but I'm not sure
what you're missing.
I guess the thing to think of
is what do you use energy for.
I used it for my electric
toothbrush this morning.
That's an energy service.
Energy powered that
little machine.
That's something
that energy did.
I mean, you don't
want electricity.
You want things that
electricity runs.
I care about keeping
the food cold.
I get no utility from
the electricity that
runs through the refrigerator.
The service is
keeping the food cold.
the refrigeration.
The energy input is
the energy input.
That's produced by
energy and capital.
Capital in the refrigerator
energy comes into it.
Now, we'll come back.
What else have I got for you?
Oh, there's Germany.
Germany also uses a fair
amount of nuclear, which it
says it's going to shut down.
And it has shut
down a fair amount.
It also uses coal.
It also buys electricity,
and will probably
buy more electricity
from France if it shuts
those nuclear plants down fast.
Germany, again, has coal,
but doesn't really--
it does have coal, but it
really doesn't have natural gas
and it doesn't have
any oil to speak of.
There again, you'll see
it's importing a ton of oil
and exporting some.
And this has got to
be refined product,
and less stuff just gets shipped
through on a tanker somehow.
But actually,
that's interesting.
This has got to be heat.
You'll notice it uses
this particular color
for electricity.
And then coming out of
here is this red band.
In a lot of countries,
much more than in the US,
power plants provide
heat to nearby buildings.
So it's called district heating
or combined heat and power.
And that has to be what this red
is, because it's not nuclear.
This has got to be heat
going to nearby industry.
Anything else weird here?
Not much, except you'll see
solar going into commercial.
Germany has big solar
subsidies, and that may actually
be solar panels on the roofs
of warehouses and stores.
It may be big enough to
register, even in 2007.
Anything else here?
Oh, and the natural gas export--
most of Germany's natural gas
comes from Russia.
So if you want to worry
about energy security,
worry about energy security.
And that's just transshipment
of some Russian gas.
This is Japan.
Now if you want to worry
about energy security,
look over on the left.
Everything is imported.
Nuclear power's important.
Nuclear plants are being
shut down, or are shut down.
I'm not sure whether there's
anything currently running
at the moment.
You wonder why Japan
is energy efficient.
Suppose you're having
a political debate
about energy policy, and you
look at the left-hand side
of this graph.
And you worry about
energy security,
and you say, well, we
can build nuclear plants
and develop an efficient nuclear
industry, which they've done.
Not clear what else you can do
but be efficient in energy use.
Small houses, taxes on energy
to hold down consumption,
and so on and so forth.
So to some extent, the natural
endowment and other things
will drive the local policy,
will drive the energy mix.
So let's leave the
developed world.
There is a middle
income neighbor, Mexico.
Mexico has oil.
Mexico is a significant
oil exporter.
Mexico's oil production
is declining.
So Mexico has a
long-term problem,
but it heavily uses its
oil and its natural gas
to generate electricity.
What else do I want to say?
Oh, all of these
have electricity
going into transportation.
And that's not electric
cars in Mexico in 2007.
That's railroads
and mass transit.
So what else do
we see in Mexico?
Not too much.
Anything grab you?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that
all their solar energy
is going directly to
commercial, and that [INAUDIBLE]
use electricity.
What do you think that
they might be using it for,
on the commercial level?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Hot
water would be my guess.
Solar hot water is a pretty
mature, pretty widespread
technology.
I'm surprised we
don't see more of it
residential, because that's
a pretty good climate for it.
And electricity is not that
cheap or reliable in Mexico.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] had
my hand raised before that.
I'm just going to ask
something more general.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that
for Germany, [INAUDIBLE]
in Japan [INAUDIBLE] nuclear.
I just though, given
their endowments,
that especially for Germany,
making such a hard decision
about closing all their
nuclear, I just didn't know--
a general comment
about countries.
Why would you just go ahead
and purchase a huge blow
to yourself?
Because you don't have
so many other resources?
[INAUDIBLE] so maybe
they're scared,
so they want to veer
away from the nuclear.
But given their situation,
as you said other,
than being extra
efficient, you may be
forced to go down some roads.
And I'm just curious to see
why any political process,
or lobbying, or whatever could
have happened to lead you
down the quite tricky
road, especially
with nuclear generators shutting
down on a very small fraction,
if I remember correctly.
And they have to
replace that with,
what, the natural gas in Russia.
[INAUDIBLE] Russia [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's caused
a lot of people outside Germany
to scratch their heads.
But you got to remember, Germany
has a very, very powerful Green
Party.
The environmental
movement in Germany
is stronger than here--
stronger than a lot of places.
It was a political calculation.
Mrs. Merkel is not crazy
and she's not dumb.
So to answer that question--
I mean, I've read answers.
I can't reproduce
them because I don't
know the German
system that well,
but that's a
political calculation.
It remains to be seen how
quickly they do it, in fact.
It remains to be seen what
the public reaction is going
to be when they realize how
much nuclear electricity
they're importing from
France right next door
and elsewhere to fill the gap.
They are also heavily committed
to renewables, and have been.
They're going to spend
a lot of money building
offshore windmills, which won't
replace nuclear power plants,
because the wind
doesn't always blow,
but that's part of the
political calculus.
If you were a green eyeshade
economist, and you said,
well, the public
overstates the risk--
Germany doesn't have
that many tidal waves,
these reactors are inland,
we're not earthquake prone,
these facilities are much
safer, what we really should do
is take a deep breath, review
our safety considerations,
and go on, and
reconsider how much we
want to do with nuclear versus
renewables going forward.
But that's a green eyeshade
cost-benefit calculation.
The political world, as
we will discuss next week,
is not always the
green eyeshade world.
It's a world in which you may do
things because of their impact
on your political
situation, on your ability
to get something else done, or
your ability to maintain office
or a variety of other things
that have economic costs.
Not irrational, but a
different kind of calculation,
which I hope at the end
of this semester we all
come a little closer
to understanding.
But that's a hard one.
That one in particular is hard.
People gasped.
Even knowledgeable
people gasped.
The current, or is he former,
German foreign minister,
who came from the Green
Party, spoke at MIT
toward the end of last
semester about that.
And I went to the talk, and
I actually went to dinner
with him afterward.
And it still isn't clear to
say what they were thinking
and why, because I don't know
German politics well enough.
OK, good question.
There's China.
China, you'll notice,
has a lot of coal,
and their electricity
is driven--
2007 is true, still
true, driven by coal.
We have a lot of coal.
China has a lot of coal.
They burn the coal.
Building power plants
at a rapid rate.
That's the main
story here I think
that's of any interesting.
This is India.
India is not as
wealthy as China.
India has some coal.
Oil is imported.
Now you see biomass in
the residential area,
oddly enough, much
more important in India
than in China, structure
of villages and so forth.
But this is an estimate
now, basically,
of wood being burned
to cook, rather than
other fuels being used.
And electricity is
again dominated by coal.
Most of the oil is imported.
with again, some exports, which
have to be refined product.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So a lot
of the breakdowns
we've been looking at
are all by the country.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But some of these
countries are really big.
Would it make sense,
especially for internal policy,
to look at different
regions, especially
like in India and China?
I feel like this big picture
blurs things together.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, you're right.
These are the data we have.
There's some work
ongoing at MIT,
in the joint program on
the Science and Policy
of Global Change to
model China regionally.
And of course, you can
model the US regionally.
That model exists.
And when you do Europe,
you're modeling,
to some extent,
bite-sized countries.
But you're right.
India and China are anomalous.
I think that the
basic story, coal
is the big driver, that's true.
They're putting photovoltaics
in Western China,
but the big story is coal
and some offshore oil.
Similarly in India,
but of course,
you don't have cooking
fires in downtown Mumbai.
So this notion
that there's a lot
of mass going into residential
use, that's true in aggregate.
It's not true everywhere.
Can't be true everywhere.
There are places in
the deserts where
there isn't that
much wind, and there
are metropolitan
areas where it's
tough to gather wood to cook.
So you're right, these
are big countries.
Doing this was heroic.
As I say, there are projects
on now to disaggregate China.
But they aren't that good--
they aren't that good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that almost
all the electricity and heat
that India generates goes
to this rejected energy.
Is that just because
they're using
inefficient,
outdated generators?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That
would be my guess, yeah.
Yeah, I hadn't noticed that.
But you're right, as
compared to-- let's see.
Yeah, just by i
the relative size
of the useful and the wasted
are different in China,
where the plants are
newer than in India.
Yeah, I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] stay
there, the electricity grid.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, that's true, too.
The Chinese grid is
much more modern.
China has a lot of
very high voltage lines
that are quite new.
Their losses are less.
So also, often, you
measure rejected
as the difference between
stuff that's generated
and stuff that gets paid for.
So a lot of these countries
have huge numbers for losses,
and a lot of that's theft.
I don't know if
that's true here,
but I know it's
true in some places.
OK, there's India.
Just for humor,
here's Saudi Arabia.
[CHUCKLES]
They use oil and
gas for everything.
Don't bother with anything else.
And they appear to
import wood for fires.
I don't know what that's about.
But you notice all the
biomass is, imported
and it's all residential.
And I assume that
fires for show.
I don't know what that is.
And there is a poor
country, and poor countries
tend to look like that.
A lot of biomass, all
the oil is imported,
all the coal's imported, little
snippets of other things.
And then just to really get
there, there's Cambodia.
Some hydro, I don't
know where it is.
Well, I do know where
it is-- not much of it.
Domestic biomass
used in residences.
All the oil is imported,
used to power motorbikes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
know what biomass is?
I know it shows it on the left
side of the box [INAUDIBLE]
domestic, but it doesn't do that
for wood, [INAUDIBLE],, hydro,
and solar energy.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
here, there isn't any.
Hydro is domestic.
If you import electricity as
they do, it shows up here.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
So biomass always comes up
on the left side of the box,
even though it's still domestic,
whereas like solar and hydro
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I'm not sure.
There is some-- I'm
not sure what you mean.
AUDIENCE: The source is biomass
as domestic, as well as solar,
or geothermal, or--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I think
solar and geothermal are
by definition
domestic, since these
are used except for solar,
for hot water, and so forth.
These are used for electricity
and they're domestic.
You don't import sun.
You import electricity.
So I don't know how
this is powered,
but you import electricity.
You don't import.
I mean, if you had a
line to a nuclear plant
across the border,
you might count it.
But electricity is electricity.
OK, so I want to close
with a little bit of data
on rich countries
and poor countries.
And this is something.
You should see you will
see data lots of places,
in some of the assignments,
that relate to the OECD.
This is just for
your background.
This is who the OECD is.
It's basically a
rich countries club,
Organization for Economic
Cooperation and Development,
with a few not quite
so rich countries
that have entered recently
under US and other sponsorship.
So we pulled in
Mexico and Chile.
We probably pulled
in Korea as well.
Korea is getting to
be a rich country.
It began, it was Japan, Western
Europe, and North America.
But you see, it's just under
18% of the world population,
almost half of the
world's energy use.
You don't go too far
wrong thinking of this
is the rich countries club.
So I want to do a little rich
and poor here going forward
in aggregate, not
country by country.
This is energy use.
This is from the EIA assignment.
This is energy use actual,
the first three bars,
and projected.
But this is a pretty
standard projection.
The growth is expected
to come outside the OECD.
17 and 1/2% rich
country population
of the world, half
the energy use.
You see by the time
you get to 2030, 2035,
it's well under
half the energy use.
Some growth in rich countries,
most of the growth outside.
If you do the numbers,
this is one of those--
suppose the world had actual
OECD energy per capita.
All else equal, that
would increase world
use-- this is just
doing percentages.
This would increase
world consumption
by a factor of almost 3.
If the whole world had
us energy per capita,
it would increase world
consumption by a factor of 4.
No growth-- just take
a snapshot of 2009.
Those are scary numbers.
And of course, there
will be growth.
This is where is
it going to happen.
And you'll see the
projection-- and again,
up to 2008, the actual, and
we're getting close to 2015,
is non-OECD Asia.
What is non-OECD Asia?
Non-OECD Asia is
mainly India and China,
and Indonesia for that
matter, but it's mainly
India and China.
So here's coal consumption.
Recall, I said the coal
market share has been growing.
Where is that coming from?
Non-OECD Asia-- India and China.
You will recall India and
China have a lot of coal.
India and China, as they move
out of poverty, are burning it.
Not unreasonable at
one level, but that's
how you get CO2
emissions growth.
This is world energy-related
CO2 emissions, OECD, non-OECD.
What's the growth?
The growth is non-OECD
Asia burning coal largely--
largely.
So again, if you run
these kinds of numbers,
suppose the world got to
where the OECD is, or suppose
the world got to where
the US is, forget growth.
After that, you'd have CO2
emissions up by a multiple.
As we will discuss when
we talk about climate--
we'll talk about climate
a little bit next time
and more later, that's scary.
If you go to double CO2
emissions, that's scary.
But if I'm a poor country,
I say, wait a minute.
You guys burned your coal.
You're using much more energy
than we are per capita.
You got rich.
Don't we get a
chance to get rich?
You guys sit in fancy
classrooms at MIT
and try hard to stay
awake and all of that.
Don't we get to do that?
So we'll come back
to this, because I
think this is one of the
great issues of the day.
I'm going to close with
some final thoughts.
I hope you got that
there's a lot of diversity.
Some of it comes from resources.
But some of it comes from
culture and some of it
comes from politics,
and some of it
comes from a variety of
technology, efficiency,
history-- a variety of reasons.
The last point, which will be
a very important point going
forward, which is we
expect the growth to come
in the future,
absent anything else,
from the developing world--
if the rest of the world gets
rich the way we got rich,
there will be enormous increases
in energy use, which may not
be feasible, and in
CO2 emissions, which
at least your children
and grandchildren will not
like much.
I know that's an
impossible thought,
but you will have children
and grandchildren.
And this is something
we'll be talking about.
That's hard.
We know how we got rich.
We burned fossil
fuels, and we used
that to acquire capital
stock and knowledge,
and build universities and
do all those great things.
But that won't work--
that won't work.
What will work, you got me.
That's what you guys are for.
OK, any questions or
comments, reactions, thoughts?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said
something in the last class.
Most of the US
energy [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's true, right?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's true, right.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to
explain that more as you go on?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Which part would
you like explained?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK,
we'll talk about that
when we go sector by sector.
But an awful lot of
the infrastructure
is in regulated areas.
So part of the reason you
could raise private capital
was the capital
wasn't hugely at risk.
So for electric
power, for instance,
if you build a power plant, the
regulator says yeah go ahead,
you would get a return
on your investment.
That makes it easier.
We'll come back to that.
OK, thank you.